no that's a huge shift for for 200 years
since the birth of the northeastern
penitentiary the stated purpose of
incarceration if not the reality mind
you was to grab hold of wayward citizens
who had done wrong and to intervene in
their lives in such a way that they
would come out the other side of
incarceration better than they had
entered now this never really worked out
it was never even really attempted to
the full extent but because that was the
stated purpose and because there was a
kind of higher calling in theory to
Corrections that kind of mitigated the
extent to which you know vengeance and
neglect and retribution could dominate
the correctional experience but that
that really has changed in the last 40
years rehabilitation which reached its
zenith kind of under the federal system
and the California system in the 60s
came under attack by the left and more
aggressively under attack from the right
and has really been squashed such that
the purpose we have now for imprisoning
so many people is on much more shaky
ground philosophically it's to
incapacitate people from committing
crimes we say it's for deterrence but
the evidence for deterrence is extremely
weak people are deterred by the
president's presence of of car alarms or
police but you know before a drug addict
breaks into your car to steal your
stereo they do not consult sentencing
schedules to find out if the penalty in
Maryland is harsher than the penalty in
Virginia and it's silly of us to think
that that would happen it definitely
also doesn't work as deterrence so it's
really incapacitation but that's a very
expensive way to prevent crime and help
Public Safety and it doesn't work very
well what the collapse of for me and my
work what the collapse of the
rehabilitative claim and the collapse of
Corrections as a framework for thinking
about incarceration has done as really
brought into clearer view an alternative
tradition of American punishment not a
tradition that has its genesis in
northern churches and Quaker meeting
houses and genteel reform movements as
is the traditional story told about the
north and as a traditional story you'll
find in almost history any history book
about prisons but an alternative
genealogy comes into view that really
stretches back through racially divisive
politics and it stretches back to
segregation it stretches back to convict
leasing the totally privatized
incredibly brutal prison system that
took root in the south after the Civil
War and stretches ultimately back to
slavery and that's a tradition of
intentional debasement public vengeance
exploitation of labor and racial control
and in many ways that sadly is the
genealogy I think that gives us a more
accurate sense of where we have ended up
in the present than the trappings of
rehabilitation that have dominated the
historical literature
what we have done of course is the
opposite in a sense forty years ago it's
as if we sat down and thought okay we
have this problem of crime and and crime
was going up in the 1960s let's figure
out the most expensive most ineffective
way to deal with crime that will produce
the most kind of social stratification
and collateral damage and will undo a
lot of the progress that's going on
towards civil rights
no one said around and did that at the
time not even the hardest hard liners
but that is in effect what we have done
for 40 years we have legislated by
headline we have legislated by fear and
campaign announcement we have not
governed in the interest of effective
public policy but we have let
partisanship trump common sense and
we've been very tough on crime but but
not very smart on crime at all and it's
gonna take a lot of effort to undo it
but I think you're exactly right what
needs to happen is we need to have as a
central goal not just trying to make
conditions of confinement more humane or
help people who are released from prison
there's like 750,000 people a year who
get out of prison they're tossed out on
the street with stigma without money
angrier and more alienated than they
were before they didn't get much
treatment behind bars so there's a lot
of emphasis on rape reentry right now as
well there should be but in my view
there really has to be an emphasis on
reduction of this out-of-control bloated
government bureaucracy that is causing
and it's unlike other types of
government waste I mean if we have a
contract to build a highway and it gets
double billed or air marshals take air
marshals for example which it seems like
now that the evidence is in has been a
totally useless government program they
haven't committed any crime there's been
an average of four arrests a year but
it's relatively benign people get jobs
no one really is harmed by it maybe
there's a little bit of public safety so
it's more or less it's wasteful it's
it's irresponsible use of taxpayer money
but it's not harming anyone prison is
very different it actually is most
people think
that is responsible maybe for 1020
percent of reducing crime in the United
States there are many better
cost-effective ways to reduce crime and
we haven't done them and we need to
start kind of changing direction there
are signs that's happening and it there
need to be changes at every level of the
system we need better indigent defense
we need fairer trials we need a shift in
our approach to addiction toward
thinking about it as a medical problem
entwined with crime and poverty problem
rather than as a crime as a solely
criminal justice issue we need to think
about better ways to let more people out
of prison especially as they pass beyond
their criminal prime there is a
promising piece of legislation in the in
Congress right now that Senator Webb of
Virginia is pushing to create a national
criminal justice commission to look at
the whole u.s. criminal justice system
especially the federal but also in the
states at every stage from arrest to
parole and to think about to bring
together experts from across disciplines
and perspectives and to try to actually
for the first time in 40 years look at
this problem in a sober minded way
rather than in a partisan divisive way
and that hasn't happened since President
Johnson's crime Commission in 1967 which
if you go back and dust that off is a
pretty great document they had a whole
laundry list of reforms the prison
population was 300,000 and their day and
they thought that was too high they had
a whole series of recommendations for
enhancing Public Safety by preventing
child abuse with more effective policing
with better public housing with
after-school programs as well as more
effective law enforcement techniques and
a better targeting of our criminal
justice resources which are so
disproportionately devoted to drug
crimes right now and not toward if the
crimes were related to be afraid of so I
think that's Prime
but in order for in order for us to undo
40 years of worrying on crime and 40
years of worrying on drugs it's going to
take a lot more than the sort of budget
driven minor reforms that many of the
states are undertaking now and I think
it's gonna take leadership from
President Obama and Congress to make
this an issue on par with health care or
banking reform and it really should be I
mean in in President Obama's inaugural
address he said that we want to carry
this great gift of freedom that
Americans have carried over the course
of our history or at least tried to
carry through the better chapters of our
history and deliver it safely to future
generations we cannot do that we cannot
carry the torch of freedom into the 21st
century with having built the free
world's version of the gulag with 2.4
million Americans behind bars with more
than a million African Americans having
lost the vote it fundamentally
undermines our claims to democratic
leadership in the same way segregation
did during the Cold War in the same way
I believe that slavery was the great
contradiction to the founding of the
American democratic experiment
you